the planet earth
a blue paradise in space
is it the only habitable planet in the
universe
or are there other places somewhere out
there
where life could be possible
it's a question that's long interested
scientists and has become a key field of
research
scientists in potsdam are studying
planets that we already know exist
they want to know whether they could
support life
looking for planets outside our solar
system that might be habitable is
complex for a number of reasons
the problem with discovering extra solar
planets is that the light of the central
star outshines the light of the planet
when you look at the sky all you see is
the stars not their planets which may
well exist
small rocky planets like earth can only
be discovered from space
as only they pass in front of their sun
that's why the u.s space agency nasa
sent the kepler space telescope into
space
kepler is equipped with a main mirror
about a meter and a half in diameter
its mission is to track down habitable
planets by studying the stars
if a planet passes in front of its star
the light of the star is dimmed ever so
slightly
the satellite has to detect the tiniest
fluctuations in the star's light to
discover the planet
if the earth passes in front of the sun
for example
the sun's light decreases by just 0.01
percent
another problem is that these so-called
planetary transits are extremely rare
so the kepler satellite focused on a
larger area
honing in on the cygnus constellation
which derives its name from the greek
word for swan
there it kept a constant eye on 150 000
stars
to do that it had to be exactly aligned
so that each star retained the exact
same position on the detector
only then could kepler detect the tiny
changes in light caused by passing
planets
the next question is whether any of
these distant worlds could be habitable
that's what scientists on the ground are
now busy studying
the planet has to be orbiting in a
habitable zone not too close or too far
away from its sun
water in liquid form is necessary for
life on earth for example so if the
temperature on another planet is
somewhere between 0 and 100 degrees
centigrade then liquid water could be
there which would be positive for the
development of life
but kepler won't be finding a second
planet earth its mission was aborted in
august
two of the probes reaction wheels are
defective without these it can no longer
align itself with sufficient accuracy
the mission was going to be extended
because it was so successful
so far kepler has discovered 135 new
exoplanets
the smallest of these is only a little
larger than our moon that's tiny
but kepler's most spectacular discovery
was a planetary system that appears to
be very similar to our own
it has two earth-like planets orbiting
in the habitable zone making them the
most promising candidates in the search
for exoplanets that could support life
there are now thought to be many more
such planets than previously thought
based on kepler's discoveries we can
estimate that there are maybe 50 billion
planets in the milky way of which 500
million could be habitable
how similar these planets are to earth
and whether there really is any form of
life there will be the focus of future
missions
you